pour en arêtes temps de faire pipi
debout turcitu salut moi c'est jennifer
vous vous demandez sans doute comment je
me suis retrouvé là en fait je viens
vous annoncer une super nouvelle
il y à du nouveau sur zeste de science
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bienvenue dans notre toute nouvelle
série dédiée à notre planète terre et à
l'environnement
et qui dit environnement dit fun on va
parler de forêt qui brûle d'abeilles qui
disparaissent de tortues qui mangent du
plastique de luz et qui fondent
sauf que nous on ne veut pas vous parler
de ce qui va mal
non parce que on le sait que ça va mal à
tomber
donc ça va hyper mal tu veux dire
j'angoisse quand jean cau superbe entier
du coup je fais plein co2 ok pas de
panique nous on va vous emmener sur le
terrain à la rencontre des chercheuses
et chercheurs du cnrs qui travaille au
quotidien dans toutes les disciplines
pour tenter de mieux protéger notre
environnement dans l'espoir que notre
planète redevienne un jour un peu moins
infernal
j'ai oublié quelque chose comme ici on
est des gens très inventif on a décidé
de baptiser ce nouveau format
et oui un veste pour la planète
alors à bientôt
[Musique]